merci beaucoup
monsieur et notre invité politique ce
matin c'est François Saad bonjour
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
président centrist du département de la
Côte d'Or et président de cette
assemblée des départements de France on
est ensemble pendant un peu plus de 20
minutes François sauad à mes côté pour
vous interviewer Olivier Claudon des
dernières nouvelle d'Alsace bonjour
Olivier bonjour et qui est évidemment la
presse locale ici à Strasbourg merci
Olivier être avec nous on va évidemment
parler des enjeux he de ce congrès
longuement François sauvadé mais d'abord
forcément un mot sur l'actualité et
cette marche qui aura lieu dimanche à
l'appel de Gérard Larchet et d'El brun
pivé marche civique pour lutter contre
l'antisémitisme hier David lissnard au
nom des maires de France a appelé à des
rassemblements devant les préfectures à
15h est-ce que l'Assemblée des
départements de France que vous présidez
appelle à une initiative va prendre une
initiative ben d'abord vous savez on a
reçu le président du Sénat et je l'ai je
l'ai remercier d'ailleurs d'avoir pris
l'initiative avec la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale pour marquer notre
volonté de de de réprouver de se lever
pour dire que nous ne voulons pas voir
revenir le spectre de de de période
passée et donc effectivement quand on
voit se multiplier les actes antisémite
dans notre pays effectivement il faut
qu'ensemble toute la nation rassemblé
dise non nous ne voulons pas de ça et
donc effectivement j'ai lancer un appel
au nom des départements de France pour
que on s'associe partout à l'initiative
qui était conduite à Paris d'AB mais
vous le savez les
parlementaires les maires de France ont
souhaitit qu'on se retrouve aussi dans
chacun dans chacune des régions dans
chacun des départements nous y
participerons bien évidemment donc vous
vous joignez à cet appel de David
lissnard un rassemblement à 15h dimanche
av lcé l'appel d'ailleurs j'ai je vous
le dis hein quand on est ici au
Parlement européen on voit bien que il y
a une portée historique de vouloir pour
département de France se réunir ici on
voit bien la la la dégradation de la
situation
internationale les montées d'ACT
antisémite on voit ce qui s'est passé
avec le Hamas qui est une organisation
terroriste il faut que les mots soient
employés
clairement l'attaque contre Israël donc
ce spectre là effectivement a une portée
inquiétante mais en même temps qui
appelle a beaucoup de responsabilités
c'est la raison d'ailleurs pour laquelle
nous avons voulu nous réunir ici même à
Strasbourg parce que cette portée d'un
d'un rassemblement pour qu'on dise
ensemble ce que nous voulons ce que nous
voulons c'est-à-dire préserver les
valeurs préserver la liberté des peuples
et et préserver aussi le respect de
l'autre et voilà c'est aussi le message
qu'on veut faire passer département de
France et j'appelle évidemment toute la
nation à se lever pour dire que nous ne
voulons pas ce retour des des
communautarismes et des des actes
antiémites qui sont insupportables 1159
hein depuis le 7 d'octobre c'est trois
fois plus que le total de l'année
dernière au-delà de ces rassemblement
qui auront lieu dimanche comment et que
pouvez-vous faire vous pour lutter
contre cette résurgence de
l'antisémitisme dans le pays écoutez je
crois que d'abord ce qu'il faut c'est
c'est qu'on redonne du sens à ce que
nous voulons la situation internationale
s fortement dégradé vous l'avez vu la
guerre à nos portes en Ukraine le
Moyen-Orient et puis les conséquences
que nous vivons ici sur notre propre
pays avec avec vous l'avez dit la
rurgence des actes antisémites en même
temps des tensions très fortes dans le
pays et en plus dans un contexte de de
de changement considérable de de
transition considérable l'effet du
changement climatique avec l'arrivée de
de de migrants à nos portes vous avez vu
en Italie en France nousmême nous sommes
confrontés à ce problème donc tout ça
fait que il faut qu'on redonne du sens
qu'est-ce qu'on veut pour le 21e siècle
c'est c'est ce que nous disons nous
aussi ce que nous portons on pourra pas
simplement se contenter de de dénoncer
parce qu'il faut s'apporter des réponses
à un peuple qui s'inquiète qui est
préoccupé légitimement et qui est
confronté à beaucoup de défis pour
lesquels il ne voit pas clair de
solution la solution c'est précisément
de d'être au côté de la nation et je le
redirai à la première ministre pour que
ensemble les élus locaux qui sont les
premiers maillons de la République maire
président de département conseillers
départementaux nous puissons montrer que
les choses changent que la cohésion
nationale il a pas d'issue en dehors de
cette cohésion pas d'ISS sol sur la
marche de dimanche puisque Gérard Larché
ilbron pivé voulez une marche civique
appeler la nation à se mobiliser il y a
une polémique sur la présence du
rassemblement national qui a
immédiatement annoncé euh Marine Le Pen
et Jordane Bardella qui seraient là
est-ce que la présence du RN est un
problème pour vous dimanche écoutez on
peut pas la fois appeler au
rassemblement et distinguer les citoyens
en fonction de leur engagement vous
savez que j'ai toujours dénoncé j'ai
toujours combattu l'extrême droite
toujours de toute ma vie et je
continuerai toute ma vie mais en même
temps quand on appelle au rassemblement
appeler au rassemblement et désigner
ceux qui seraient autorisés à venir
manifester enfin franchement que le
rassemblement national quand on se
souvient des propos de Monsieur Le Pen
et quand on voit aujourd'hui qu'ils
acceptent de participer je dis qu'il
faut se rassembler et donc on ne peut
pas rassembler en commençant par diviser
donc il faut que chacun fasse preuve de
responsabilité hein quand l'enjeu est
aussi fort quand la cohésion nationale
est aussi menacée quand les actes
communautaristes sont aussi doivent être
aussi dénoncés il faut effectivement
qu'on rassemble donc on peut pas
commencer par dire on veut rassembler et
les a vous n'avez pas le droit de citer
à venir manifester alors moi par exemple
je trouve que
les fi à comportement euh absolument
invraisemblable dans notre pays qui se
rapproche de l'extrême droite est-ce
qu'on va dire et les filles vous pour
vous il se rapproche de l'extrême droite
bah bien sûr c'est c'est c'est les mêmes
fondamentaux et les filles ce sont les
mêmes fondamentaux faut avoir le courage
de le dénoncer enfin quand on voit ce
qui se passe à l'Assemblée nationale le
désordre la déstabilisation de la
République et de ses institutions le
manque de respect tout simplement à à ce
qui est issu du suffrage universel ça
relève de quoi ça relève des positions
extrêmes donc il faut le dénoncer avec
équivalence avec équivalence quand quand
la France insoumise refuse use de se
rendre à cette marche quand Jean-Luc
Mélenchon sur cette marche dit que les
amis du soutien inconditionnel au Hamas
ont leur rendez-vous qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire pour vous est-ce qu'il y a
dans les prises de position de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon de l'antisémitisme bien sûr
qu'il y a de l'antisémitisme quand il a
refusé de qualifier de terroriste une
organisation comme le Hamas enfin
franchement après ces milliers de morts
et ces enfants qui ont été égorgés ces
femmes qui ont été
battu enfin franchement faut être
sérieux on peut pas on peut pas ne pas
qualifier les choses si on veut les
combattre la première chose c'est de les
qualifier clairement on va passer à ce
congrès et aux enjeux de ce congrès de
ces Assises Nationales des départements
de France c'est ellisabeth bornne qui
conclut votre congrès la première
ministre qui sera présente qu'est-ce que
vous attendez d'Élisabeth borne
qu'est-ce qu'elle doit faire qu'est-ce
qu'elle doit dire pour que vous soyez
satisfait d'abord je suis d'abord c'est
une très bonne chose que la la chef de
gouvernement Vienne clôturer nos assises
parce qu'on est dans un contexte parti
circulièrement complexe et les
départements de France sont en première
ligne vous l'avez vu première ligne des
solidarités on est confronté à à une à à
une montée des précarités dans le pays
le choc énergétique le choc alimentaire
il y a beaucoup de familles qui ne s'en
sortent pas évidemment nous qui sommes
en charge des solidarité on est en
première ligne on prend nous-même ce
choc et donc je je l'ai dit je le
redirai tout à l'heure à Elisabeth borne
elle le sait nous avons été encore en
contact hier avant-hier nous avons nous
avons une situation intenable pour les
départements France pour la première
fois nous avons une explosion de nos
dépenses sociales et en même temps une
chute de nos ressources donc on va droit
dans le mur et on pourra pas faire face
aux responsabilités qui sont les notes
si on ne fait pas jouer la solidarité
nationale donc on peut pas sur la
protection de l'enfance nous pointer du
doigt en disant vous ne faites pas assez
comme si l'État pourrait faire mieux que
nous qui sommes en proximité pour
protéger les enfants et dans le même
temps ne pas apporter des réponses
notamment financière de solidarité
nationale c'est pareil pour le
bienveillir on peut pas afficher des
ambitions de bienveillir sans même même
qu'il y ait 1 € de plus consacré dans le
projet de loi de finance pour nous
accompagner dans les sur le virage
domiciliaire pour accompagner les gens à
rester chez eux avec le vieillissement
et pour faire mieux pour leur accueil
dans les épades donc je vais lui dire
clairement les choses on sait très bien
qu'on est face à des difficultés mais
vous savez c'est dans le fossé des des
annonces enans lendemain que se creuse
la désillusion et la colère du peuple et
nous qui sommes en première ligne nous
allons poser simplement les problèmes
nous sommes dans le bateau France on
veut gagner cette bataille de France
dans les turbulences il faut qu'élus
locaux et gouvernement travaillent
ensemble sérieusement sans se renvoyer
la balle et en disant VO pas travaz pas
bien ensemble écoutez on travaille bien
ensemble on voit bien il y a un an
j'alertais déjà dans le loté Garon
j'alertais sur la situation des
départements et j'entendais Bruno Le
Maire me dire mais non tout va bien vous
avez des droits de mutation et quand je
voyais s envolé des dépenses que nous
avons vécu songez dans un département
comme le mien nous avons tr 320 millions
de dépenses sur l'action sociale
sociétale l'aide à domicile les
personnes âgées la protection de
l'enfance le RSA l'insertion 320
millions 40 millions d'euros de dépenses
en plus en un an 40 millions de dépenses
nécessairire et légitime he je pense
notamment à la revalorisation des des
salaires pour les métiers de la vie mais
dans le même temps un effondrement des
droits de mutation on a déjà connu des
périodes difficiles en 2008 quand il y
avait les subprimes on avait une chute
de nos ressources mais là on prend tout
le choc et en plus l'inflation qui nous
est pas compensé et en plusalimentation
dans nos collèges et en plus les taux
d'intérêt très élevé donc évidemment
qu'on va droit dans le mur donc je vais
lui poser clairement voilà la question
les droits de mutation liés à le la
baisse des transactions sur le marché
immobilier donc c'est une chute très
importante ah oui et puis la chute est
brutale si vous voulez les droits de
mutation c'est ce qu'on appelle les les
notaire les frais de notaires
c'est-à-dire que quand vous avez une
transaction immobiliiare ben vous
percevez d' 5 % en fonction du taux que
vous avez décidé avec un plafond vous
percevez cette somme vous la percevez
tous les 3 mois donc ça va très vite
mais vous voyez bien la hausse des taux
d'intérêt la crise bah évidemment la
précarité qui monte les marches de de la
des classes moyennes donc des
difficultés à vivre et puis vous avez
des taux d'intérêt élevés un accès au
crédit difficile évidemment que le
marché d'immobilier trinque très vite et
donc là par exemple en ce moment nous
avons fait nous avons fait un un test
auprès de tous les départements de
France la baisse est de l'ordre de 20%
dans certains départements de 40 % alors
justement il il y a quelques jours vous
disiez qu'il y avait une quinzaine de
départements qui étaient en en en
difficultés financières assez
importantes ça se traduit concrètement
par quoi quelles sont les décisions
qu'ils sont amenés à prendre ça se
traduit tout simplement qu'ils pourront
même plus faire face à leurs obligations
légales réglementaires de versement des
allocations individuelles de solidarité
c'est quoi ces allocations c'est le RSA
pour les personnes qui sont au bord du
chemin c'est l'aide la pas c'est-à-dire
pour les personnes âgées et c'est
notamment la la PCH pour les personnes
handicapées quand même vous pouvez plus
faire face au versement des prestations
que légalement vous êtes conduit à
verser à nos compatriotes et ben
effectivement vous êtes vous êtes dans
la capacité de faire ça sur une
quinzaine de départements pour lesquels
j'ai demander l'aide du gouvernement
nous avons nous-même joué le jeu hein on
est la seule strate de collectivité à
avoir fait la solidarité entre nous ce
qu'on appelle des péréquations
horizontales mais maintenant on a besoin
de l'accompagnement de l'État donc vous
attendez des annonces aujourd'hui ques
sont les annonces que vous attendez de
la prre minist oui trois sujets sur
lesquels j'attends des réponses
d'abord premier sujet c'est celle des
départements c'est celui des
départements en difficulté les 15
départements il y a les ardenes il y a
la beus différents département bref même
le Nord qui est confronté à de grosses
difficultés S et d'autres on doit
apporter des réponses c'està-dire que on
ne peut pas laisser supporter à la
solidarité départementale ce qui relève
de la solidarité nationale donc mais
mais pardon François sauad mais ça fait
des années qu'à chaque congrès on entend
le le même discours pourquoi ça n'avance
pas non on n'entend pas le même discours
parce que je ça fait des années que vous
demandez vous à l'état de plus vous
aider que le reste à charge augmente de
plus en plus sur ces allocations
individuelles de solidarité pourquoi il
y a pas de réponse pourquoi il y a pas
de ça fait des années parce qu'on est
face à un choc de la dépense publique et
que effectivement l'État s'est défaussé
sur les département et aujourd'hui sur
des allocations individuelles je vous
l'ai dis qui relèvent dont le contour
est fixé par l'État et le montemps fixé
par l'État nous en payons département 60
% est-ce que ce sont la solidarité
départemental qui doivent assurer la
continuité de versement d'une solidarité
nationale c'est le vrai problème donc là
par contre ça j'ai j'ai tiré la solette
d'alarme il y a 1 an il ne s'est rien
passé depuis un an en terme de
solidarité financière aujourd'hui les 15
départements faut apporter des réponses
bon je l'ai dit à la première ministre
je l'ai vu on a un dialogue très très
nourri hein on est n'est pas les uns
contre les autres je ne veux pas engager
un bras de faer avec le gouvernement je
veux l'alerter sur la situation du pays
mais juste des réponses c'est quoi c'est
une enveloppe financière ou ou c'est
revoir le fléchage des des recettes pour
que vous ayez des recettes plus dynam
simplement déjà une enveloppe financière
pour leur permettre de passer le cap
cette année budgétaire donc là j'attends
100 millions d'euros supplémentaires
pour les départements la deuxème la
deuxième chose c'est qu'on est face à un
choc migratoire considérable vous l'avez
vu on va on va accueillir 17000 jeunes
migrants de plus dans notre pays on va
avoir 44000 migrants c'est c'est un coup
pour les départements de 2 milliards
d'euros est-ce que vous croyez qu'on
pourra supporter ce choc migratoire donc
il y a un débat au Parlement en ce
moment sur la migration on va en parler
pardon parce c'est un sujet important
effectivement il y a il y a le le projet
de loi immigration qui est examiné en ce
moment au Sénat est-ce que vous
regretter qu'il n'y ait pas de mesures
sur pour aider les départements à faire
face à cet accueil des mineurs étrangers
isolés c'est pas l'objet de cette loi
l'objet de cette loi c'est face au fait
migratoires quelle est la politique de
la France la France doit conduire on
peut pas comme l'a dit le président de
la République l'a dit accueillir tous
les toute la misère du monde donc ce que
nous demandons simplement c'est que nous
avons la responsabilité des MNA de la
protection des des enfants nous
l'assumons nous l'assumons clairement et
je crois avec humanité et avec
responsabilité simplement quand vous
avez un afflu on est en train
d'emboliser nos systèmes ce que nous
demandons c'est que tant quand un jeune
arrive tant qu'il n'est pas reconnu
mineur il faut qu'il soit pris en charge
par l'État c'est pas les départements de
France qui doivent prendre en charge le
phénomène migratoire évidemment dans
notre pays ça concerne puis il y a des
départements qui sont très exposés les
Alpes Maritimes tout ce qui est sur la
façade avec l'Italie l'Espagne enfin
tout ce qui est dans le pourtour
méditerranéen donc ce que je demande
c'est une prise en charge ensuite donc
une prise en charge de la période de
mise à l'abri jusqu'à évaluation de la
minorité
des jeunes voilà et on a un débat entre
nous vous avez entendu Jean-Luc G un
débat entre nous en tout cas la position
de département de France c'est que nous
voulons rester en charge de l'évaluation
des des milurs parce qu'on peut pas en
même temps nous dire l'État va se
charger d'évaluation et c'est vous qui
allez prendre la conséquence de cette
évaluation pourquoi c'est si important
surtout que Charlotte cobel vous a
répondu qu'elle était contre le
découpage de la protection de l'enfance
c'est que si c'était ça le gouvernement
était prêt à recentraliser toute la
protection oui enfin Charlotte cobel
elle a pas dit que ça hein elle a
commencé à laisser entendre à un moment
donné d'ailleurs je me suis exprimé
fortement que l'État ferait mieux que
nous dans la protection de l'enfance
enfin franchement quand on voit la
situation de la PJJ c'està-dire pour les
fites délinquen on nous laisse les
jeunes qui ont été dans l'attente de
leur procès on nous les reconfie quand
on voit la situation de l'état de la
santé psychiatrique et psychique
franchement madame cobel devrait déjà
s'occuper de la responsabilité de l'État
et puis qui peut penser un seul instant
qui peut penser un seul instant que le
retour des dasses dans temps permettrait
mieux de mieux traiter la protection de
l'enfance dans un monde on voit surgir
les violences juvénil pas simplement les
violences de parents à enfants ou
d'adultes à enfant maintenant il y a des
parents qui nous demandent de les
protéger de leur propre jeûes vous
l'avez vu les phénomènes dans dans les
dans la rue de violence juvénile donc on
est on se sent bien seul alors je dis à
Madame cobel assumez votre
responsabilité prenez en charge le fait
migratoire aidez-nous dans les
problématiques de santé qui relève de
l'état de santé mentale il y a 17
départements songés qui n'ont plus aucun
pédopsychiatre
ouais sur ces mineurs étrangers isolés
il y a aussi un un sujet il en était
beaucoup question au Sénat ces derniers
jours parce que vous dites c'est pas
l'objet de la loi mais il est beaucoup
question des départements et de la prise
en charge de cmna par les départements
en ce moment au Sénat il y a notamment
la loi taqu de février 2022 qui vous
interdit de loger ces mineurs dans les
hôtels est-ce qu'il faut revenir
là-dessus ah ben écoutez vous savez la
loi peut interdire tout ce qu'on veut il
y a un problème
d'humanité qu'est-ce qu'on fait quand il
y a plus de place vous vous avez des
systèmes qui sont embolisés c'est-à-dire
que nous n'avons plus de place pour
accueillir des jeunes en situation de
migrant nous n'avons plus de place
qu'est-ce qu'on fait on les laisse dans
la rue ou on les met à l'hôtel j'ai
clairement indiqué au préfet dans mon
département que je les protégerai que je
les metett à l'hôtel alors évidemment on
met pas jeunes femmes et cetera ou des
des mineurs à risque mais les les jeunes
mineurs qui ont 17 ans qui sont
pratiquement qui ont déjà eu des
parcours o ils ont traversé des des
épreuves considérable je crois que notre
responsabilité c'est d'abord lesp mais
ce que vous nous dites c'est que dans
tous les cas vous êtes obligé
d'enfreintre quelque part vos
obligations légales soit vous les mettez
à poser comme ça le problème non mais
soit vous êtes obligé de les mettre à
l'hôtel ce que désormais la loi vous
interdit soit vous n'êtes plus en
capacité de les accueillir alors que la
loi vous oblige à les accueillircoutez
je j'ai une responsabilité pénale comme
président de département comme
l'ensemble de mes collègues c'est celle
de protéger les jeunes mineurs ma
responsabilité c'est de les protéger
elle est supérieure à a tout autre
priorité que l'État me dise vous ne les
mettez pas à l'hôtel je l'entends parce
que en même temps on ne les met pas à
l'hôtel de manière de manière spontan
vous on pas d'aut Cho on les accompagne
dans l'hôtel c'est-à-dire que nous avons
des travailleurs sociaux qui les
accompagnent ils sont suivis dès lors
qu'ils sont alors il y a deux situations
je le répète pour être très clair il y a
la situation de ceux qui ne sont pas
encore reconnus mineurs et que donc qui
se prétendent mineur et que nous
protégeons dans l'attente de
reconnaissance ou nom de leur mineur
c'est ce tempsl qui doit être assumé par
l'État ce n'est pas à nous de le faire
songez que dans dans tous les
départements de France sur sur tous les
jeunes qui se prétendent mineurs après
enquête et après évaluation 70 % d'entre
eux se révèlent majeurs donc pendant
cette période il faut que l'État assume
sa responsabilité on va parler d'un
autre sujet Olivier avec vous de la
sécurité dans les collèges
oui est-ce qu'il y a un sujet pour vous
de autour du financement de la Sécurité
tion des collèges il y a eu au mois
d'août à Lisieux le décès d'un d'un
principal hors temps scolaire est-ce que
c'est une question pour vous il y a des
demande de sécurisation d'intervention
et il est préconisé au personnel qui
logent sur place de ne pas intervenir
est-ce que c'est un sujet pour vous al
bien sûr le sujet de la sécurité c'est
un sujet pour l'ensemble de la France
comment se prémunir sans bunquériser les
collèges sans bunquériser l'école qui
doit rester un lie ouvert mais en même
temps on voit bien l'inquiétude du corps
professoral l'inquiétude de la
communauté éducative inquiétude de nos
agents dans les collèges donc ça ça date
pas d'aujourd'hui hein dès les premiers
actes de d'agression et de d'actes
terroristes nous avons engagé des
procédures de protection il faut le
faire au cas par cas moi j'ai réuni
récemment encore tous les principaux de
collèges et les gestionnaires pour leur
dire quelles sont les mesures de
sécurisation dont vous avez besoin pour
vous sentir protégé et donc on a
travaillé avec la police la gendarmerie
avec l'Éducation nationale à des process
de protection pour éviter à la fois les
intrusions et puis s'il y a un acte qui
est commis pour permettre aussi
l'évacuation donc il faut à la fois
éviter les intrusion et favoriser les
évacuations en cas d'acte d'acte
terroriste ou d'actes violent de
violence
donc on pourra pas sécuriser à 100 %
vous avez vu des des jeunes parfois
qui qui dérapent et qui se livrent à des
actes délictueux ou des actes de
violence donc on a déjà depuis une
dizaine d'années ça engage évidemment
dans le périmètre du collège si dans la
périphérie par pour ce qui concerne les
collèges et les départements la
périphérie on travaille avec les
communes les caméras de surveillance des
boutons d'alerte protégé c'est notre
priorité Olivier sur fautécole reste un
lieu serein un lieu ouvert mais en même
temps protégé sur la question de la
décentralisation Olivier oui le
président de la République a confié une
mission à Eric vert qui est chargé de
d'explorer des pistes pour pour
simplifier le millefeuille territorial
est-ce que vous vous avez une idée de la
strade qui qu'il faudrait éventuellement
supprimer écoutez franchement quand j'ai
lu la lettre de de du président de la
République à Eric vert disant nous
allons relancer le processus de
décentralisation je me suis dit enfin ça
fait des mois des mois et des mois que
nous disons il faut il faut vraiment
redonner du souffle de la liberté locale
de la solidarité avec la nation et en
même temps voilà tenir compte des
spécificités l'Alsace n'est pas n'est
pas le puit d'Ô le sens n'est pas la
Côte d'Or donc la reconnaissance de
cette diversité n'est pas un
affaiblissement de l'État c'est au
contraire lui permettre nous permettre
ensemble de mieux agir pour nos
compatriotes et d'adapter nos politiques
territorial mais quand j'ai vu qu'on
recommença à parler des strates mais
franchement je me suis demandé si on
avait continué de tirer le leçon des
crises que nous avons V on a passé 30
ans à entendre il y a trop de communes
en France on a eu la crise des gilets
jaunes et qu'est-ce qu'on a vu le
président de la République se féliciter
de la chance que nous avons d'avoir dans
chaque parcelle de territoire des élus
locaux des m donc il y a pas de strat
attendez les départements on voulait les
supprimer la crise la crise ensuite de
la covid on s'est dit quelle chance
avons-nous d'avoir des départements qui
sont en proximité qui entretiennent nos
routes qui ont des personnels qui ont
370000 agents sur le terrain pour est-ce
que vous êtes inquiet François sauvad
qu'aujourd'hui non mais est-ce qu'il
sont envisagé est-ce que vous êtes
inquiet de qu'il sont envisagés de
supprimer moi je ne suis pas inquiet je
vais dire au président de la République
attendez est-ce que vous avez oublié
monsieur président tout ce que nous
avons vécu qui a montré que nous sommes
dans un système d'organisation que dont
nous sommes les héritiers d'une longue
histoire on n'est pas on n'est pas des
des états fédéraux on a eu les exemples
suisses hier ici même en Alsace de ce
qui se passe avec les votations on est
les exemples de de de d'État fédéral en
Allemagne nous ne sommes pas un État
fédéral bon nous sommes l'histoire nous
sommes le fruit d'une longue histoire
qui a montré sa pertinence d'aujourd'hui
alors qu'est-ce qui ne fonctionne pas et
qu'il faudrait faire bah faut que l'État
change sa façon d'aborder on peut pas
nous nous nous asphixier financièrement
nous priver de toute liberté financière
et d'autonomie fiscale et dans le même
temps nous donner des injonctions
permanentes parce qu'on est en train
d'étouffer à se fixer le pays voilà donc
si on veut réveiller la démocratie
locale il faut réveiller redonner du
souffle à à la à la décentralisation ce
que je vais dire au président le
département unique alsacien la
collectivité européenne alszè qui est le
fruit de la fusion des anciens
départements orinbarin porte une demande
de sortir la région grandest et de
cumuler à la fois le statut de
département et de région est-ce que vous
soutenez cette cette demande de Frédéric
Berry son président bien sûr bien sûr
deux départements décident ensemble de
se forger à destin commun pour retrouver
cette identité heureuse qui était forgée
par l'histoire qui s'appelle l'Alsace
c'est partagé par la population 90 95 %
mais et et au nom de quoi on dirait aux
élus locaux au président de départ qui
ont décidé de se fusionner à la
population qui l'aspire au nom de quoi
on leur dirait c'est pas possible alors
les autres les autres présidents de
département de la région grandest ne
voit pas forcément ce projet d'un bon
bien sûr bien sûr et c'est
c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas
reproductible mais moi je souhaite de la
respiration dans le pays quand quand le
monde vacille quand vous avez autant de
désespérance vous croyez pas qu'il faut
retrouver tout simplement le contact
avec le peuple et l'entendre lorsqu'il
décide de se voir un destin commun ce
destin commun ici il est décidé il n'est
pas reproductible bien évidemment moi je
suis fervant partisan du département pas
parce que je défends des boutiques mais
parce que c'est l'intérêt de la France
c'est un périmètre pertinent pour agir
pertinent pour agir dès lors que deux
départements décident ensemble de se
travailler de de forger le destin ben je
leur dire au
N ça ça supprime de facto l'existence
des départements comme ça était le cas
en Corse comme ça comme ça sera le cas
comme ça é le ce que je souhaite c'est
que l'organisation territoriale elle se
fasse à partir de d'une logique c'est le
couple commune département d' alors que
les départements le souhaitent par
exemple j'ai vu en Bretagne aussi un
esprit breton une identité bretonne mais
les Bretons ne souhaitent pas la
suppression de leur département même si
la région le souhaiterait et bien voilà
le fait départemental est un fait
incontournable c'est pas une nostalgie
du passé quand j'exprime ça c'est parce
que dans un monde qui s'est globalisé
l'aspiration du peuple de la proximité
si on veut donner de la respiration dans
notre pays il faut relancer la
décentralisation et la relancer de
manière sérieuse c'est-à-dire c'est
l'État qui doit se réformer c'est pas
l'estrates qu'il faut supprimer c'est la
pratique même de la politique d'État qui
doit être rvisée la technocratie qui
doit être revu le principe même qu'on
redonne des libertés des libertés
locales et quand le président dit c'est
antinomique de parler de liberté quand
dans le même temps on va chercher la
solidarité nationale et ben c'est ça la
fr c'est la solidarité nationale et
c'est en même temps la respiration des
territoires merci beaucoup merci d'avoir
été notre invité ce matin et merci
Olivier Claudon des Dernières Nouvelles
d'Alsace on passe tout de suite au club
des territoires